يبدو ان ما خطط له قاده الحزب الجمهوري
بعد يوم واحد من ضمان الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب اصبح قيده تنفيذ اذ حددت لجنه
الرقابه في الكونغرس الامريكيه بعد غد
الجمعه
كاولى جلسات استماع لاجل الرئيس جو بايدن
هانتر بايدن حيث يتهمه الجمهوريون
بممارسات تجاريه دوليه غير شرعيه فيما
سيشمل التحقيق مع هانتر بايدن افرادا
اخرين من عائله الرئيس الجمهوريون يصرون
في مجلس النواب الامريكي على ان يجيب
مسؤول في الخزانه الامريكيه عن الاسئله
تحت القسم الاسبوع المقبل حول سبب عدم
تسليم الوكاله الوثائق المتعلقه باسره
الرئيس جو بايدن بحسب تقرير
واشار الطلب الى مواجهات محتمله حول وصول
الكونجرس الى ما يسمى تقارير الانشطه
المشبوهه حول الخدمات المصرفيه الاجنبيه
والمعاملات التجاريه الاخرى من قبل هانتر
بايدن واقارب اخرين للرئيس جوباد